we have a voicemail number that number
is two one nine two david p i know some
people are gonna be mad about this
voicemail this is a voicemail from a
caller who is sending an angry message
to bernie bros okay don't shoot the
messenger this is not my position this
is what a caller says take a listen
hey David this is Ken from Southern
California hey listen to all those
Bernie bros out there as they call
themselves you know unless you want four
more years of the [ __ ] grabber Donald
Trump who is against everything year
four then even if Joe Biden is the
nominee on the Democratic side you need
to vote for him at least he is for 75 or
80 percent of what you're for you don't
if you don't want four more years of
this [ __ ] grabbing orange piece of to
which I don't think this nation can
stand the new Bernie bros better vote
for whoever the Democratic nominee is
even if it's Joe Biden thanks David
all right so listen I mean if they're
very very angry but there is some
important message in there as I've said
before which is let's make sure that our
spirited primary doesn't end up enabling
Donald Trump to get reelected
I am a progressive therefore Joe Biden's
politics are to my right and I am going
to be supporting someone who is further
to the left
but if Biden's the nominee and it's
Biden versus Trump I'm voting for Biden
I've made it clear and I think that
that's the primary message there from
ken calling in from Southern California
we've got a great bonus show for you
today
become a member or a patron to get
instant access and we'll speak more then